[Music]
so I mean we need to tell you some of
the guys have started calling you the
Hamburglar what is it because I'm a
jumper no it's because you keep stealing
my haggis sandwich and my iron brew Luke
James life if crime is not the way to go
well maybe if you need something cool
like games developers and booby-trap
your food no one will want to pirate it
food piracy isn't even a thing get your
own damn stereotypical lunch well I'm
glad you asked friend because in fact
games developers do do lots of cool
things to help combat software piracy
what it's a Segway
all of it in Arkham Asylum The Dark
Knight Rises and then promptly falls
back to the ground developer Rocksteady
allowed pirates appetites to be
sufficiently wetted by letting them play
a good chunk of the game before they
realized that a key feature namely the
ability to glide was totally nerfed
therefore rendering the game unfinished
ball Croteam developers of Serious Sam 3
hit headlines for their creative take on
DRM if you played a cracked version of
the game it spawned well it spawned a
giant pink invincible scorpion that
hounded you throughout the game if
you're suspected of foul play with
Crysis warhead your arsenal becomes
paltry by comparison to illegally
obtained copy chicken puns for a reason
because all of your bullets and grenades
turn into them now wars aren't won with
chicken so the game is totally
unplayable when it comes to anti-piracy
measures Rockstar play hardball for gta4
they permanently enabled drunk cam which
shook the entire time that you played if
you could handle that they embedded a
fail-safe every car you got in would
auto accelerate and only drive in one
direction oh and it was always just a
light tap away from exploding remedy
entertainment didn't take such drastic
measures with Alan Wake instead
everyone's favorite Stephen King wannabe
simply wore an eye patch with a skull
and crossbones on it to guilt-trip the
Pirates almost as if to say yeah you
look me in the eye when you steal my
game spyro to Gateway to glimmer was
cracked in under a week so in
neiha games implemented some elaborate
anti cracking measures for the three
quill Year of the Dragon firstly the
fairy Zoey will tell you that your game
is an illegal copy and then the fun
begins
you can't achieve 100% completion
because collectibles will randomly start
to disappear the game will crash in odd
ways and the language will randomly
change if you do make it to the final
boss you'll last about eight seconds
before the game crashes deletes your
save file and makes you start over
and then there's game dev tycoon where
you set up and run your own game studio
the pirated version that you hit those
lofty successful highs of triple-a
development before your profits go south
and your studio has to close because you
lose all of your in-game customers to
piracy how meta piracy just saying about
swabbing decks and walking planks and
swinging grog anymore huh at all time
pirates wouldn't steal my lunch
you know they probably would you make a
really good sheeps lung sandwich yeah
[Music]
it's delicious you're Scottish you're
like programmed to say that yeah well
here he comes
dad's coming sorry dad some welcome
plant it she wouldn't steal a car' some
welcome plan SETI Mars it's gonna take
this away from you
[Music]